donc quand je suis dans une boîte je
rentre s'il est là hop il va aller là
pour éviter qu'il y a une photo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et les femmes trans ce genre hôtel
réellement leur chance au concours Miss
France pourquoi on vous dit ça parce
qu'effectivement il y a Andrea furet
c'était de concours régional pour les
Miss France qui est sorti de qu'on sait
pas si est-ce que c'est parce qu'elle
est transgenre c'est tout près
maintenant qu'on va avoir d'ailleurs
parce que c'est parce qu'elle était pas
assez jolie et nous elle règle
effectivement on peut aujourd'hui être
âgé de plus de 18 ans mesuré au moins 1
m 70 c'est désormais pour passer Miss
France être de sexe féminin à l'état
civil uniquement civile donc c'est la
coupette tranche de effectivement si
l'état civil et féminin les candidats ne
sont plus tenus d'être célibataires
voilà donc elles peuvent même avoir
accouché aussi avoir des enfants il
était étoiles sont désormais acceptés à
savoir la question qu'on se pose est-ce
qu'on peut finalement maintenant être
tout ce qu'on veut moche est une France
je ne sais pas mais moi je suis pas fan
du concours en général et je trouve que
de classer des femmes qui se ressemblent
globalement toutes pour savoir quelle
est la plus belle c'est pas mon c'est
pas mon style de beauté et c'est pas
genre de programme que je regarde donc
déjà quad 2 que ça évolue tant mieux
mais il y a encore beaucoup d'évolution
à faire ce qui est marrant c'est de voir
Elodie Gossuin qui dit par exemple on
peut pas être maman être Miss France
c'est bizarre d'abord parce qu'elle
que elle sait ce que c'est que la
maternité justement c'est pour ça que et
deuxièmement quel bizarit de dire ça
c'est à dire que tu dirais n'importe
quelle femme qui fait un boulot qui
pendant un an la prend vachement t'as
pas le droit d'avoir d'enfant tu as le
droit pour la femme tu as le droit
d'avoir une activité professionnelle qui
te prend beaucoup de temps et être maman
heureusement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le titre est qu'à la sortie parce qu'il
nous restait plus rien 60 millions
d'euros elle a quitté les réseaux
sociaux elle était vraiment dépressible
Elton John c'est son pote et Madonna
aussi et c'est Madonna qui a appelé
Elton John et qui lui dit écoute tu as
fait un truc super Dolly part va l'aider
tout ce que je vous raconte est vrai il
l'a appelé ça a donné ça c'est le
premier single qu'elle sortait depuis 6
ans ses premiers dans 40 pays ça va leur
lancer un petit peu mais c'est en
quelque sorte ils ont tué un peu sa
carrière ils ont tué sa personnalité ils
ont tué son fils ils ont tout fait ils
l'ont enfermé était dans une cage de
réel avait le droit de voir personne
dit que ces trois derniers disques que
les trois derniers 10 c'était pas elle
qui chantait de retirer son stérilet
pour qu'elle tombe enceinte mais c'est
quand même affreux alors elle elle
envoie à sa mère surtout de ne rien
avoir ça c'est une hypersensible je
pense que tout le monde a profité d'elle
à un moment donné et je peux comprendre
et concevoir qu'elle est plus envie de
parler à personne d'autre à sa famille
sa propre famille la trahi 13 ans on
peut comprendre qu'elle est pété un
câble est-ce que vous savez pire du pire
du pire ces enfants ne veulent plus
l'avoir ce qu'il fait
il ne voulait plus voir leur mère c'est
toutes ces photos et ses vidéos
horribles à moitié nues complètement un
peu dans le gaz non mais
comme il peut comme une gagne pas
d'argent
de gagner de l'argent c'est de parler la
presse people et il sait qu'en balançant
des choses il gagne de l'argent donc les
enfants entendent ça et détestent leur
mère oui mais Mathieu il y a pas que ça
parce que hier Britney Spears est revenu
sur Instagram son compte avait été
suspendus
et elle a mis un poste Instagram où elle
met tout un texte où elle explique
beaucoup de choses elle parle
principalement de son ex Kevin sederline
ou finalement elle l'accuse d'avoir
finalement monté ses enfants contre elle
donc en fait elle entre sa famille son
ex en gros elle n'a que ses enfants
ça peut pas faire les deux petites
secondes de Monsieur Jean Edouard qui
est là d'ailleurs parce que vous l'avez
vu il y a pas très très longtemps
surtout je sais pas à mon poste
[Musique]
comme ça c'est depuis quand qui vous
parle mal de place
[Applaudissements]
voilà la dernière fois j'ai voulu faire
une petite vidéo un peu drôle je crois
avoir compris que elle était mal perçue
j'avais fait un peu la folle dans ma vie
qui est là vous voyez je suis au même
endroit donc tout va bien vous inquiétez
pas il y a pas d'appel à l'aide et tout
va bien pour moi j'ai de très beaux
projets je vais vous surprendre dans le
bon sens
donc deux métiers que vous m'avez encore
jamais
c'est quoi ces projets
peut-être une dizaine de fois sur les
deux dernières années à chaque fois elle
m'a parlé d'un nouveau projet et à
chaque fois ce projet n'est pas arrivé
là elle planche sur un biopic qui
passera en téléfilm sur sa vie à elle et
elle aimerait jouer son propre rôle
non mais quelqu'un d'autre le jour et
qu'elle s'investisse dans un projet qui
peut un peu lui faire sortir la tête de
l'eau et la mettre dans le dans le
milieu entre guillemets du travail et
être entouré par exemple comme quelqu'un
que comme Alexa la rocheber par exemple
qui devrait visiblement l'épauler
là-dessus elle aimerait ça et elle
aimerait aussi beaucoup et ça je sais
pas c'est faisable mais elle aimerait
beaucoup faire partie de la bande de
TPMP avec Cyril qu'elle adore énormément
elle adore on adorerait c'est pas la
mettre à la télé
c'est qu'on est là à parler d'elle
presque chaque semaine et en fait il y a
personne qui fait rien
mais moi j'ai pas votre position
on fait tout et au final on est juste là
regardez la polémiquer sans rien faire
on m'a dit tu as eu une aventure
mais alors on a on a échappé au
paparazzi parce qu'ils étaient tout le
temps en bas de l'immeuble donc c'est
vrai donc en bas de chez moi et et il
venait je lui disais tu gardes ton
casque tu restes sur ta moto je te donne
le bip-bigard et François Hollande mais
combien de temps
à cheval sur 2007 et 2008 donc 6 ans
après la Star Academy
en même temps ça a duré quatre mois
et aujourd'hui vous êtes en colère
contre Laetitia Hallyday pourquoi c'est
pas de la colère en fait
elle fait ce qu'elle veut oui ce qu'elle
veut c'est sûr mais le problème qu'il y
a c'est qu'en fait les fans n'ont pas
d'endroits pour pour aller voir pour ce
tout simplement à part la statue qu'on a
fait de lui qui reçoit pas grand chose
et puis donc le premier cas c'est qu'en
fait je pense qu'on peut faire on peut
financer en tout cas sans vendre des
choses en tout cas garder des choses
symboliques Elvis à son à son
parce que vous auriez voulu aller vous
vous recueillir devant la maison de
marne-la-gargan
le premier cas c'est qu'en fait
effectivement on peut aller sur cueillir
on est un standard donc Saint-Barth
c'est pas donné à tout le monde on a
plus rien de Johnny en France et je
pense que les gens les fans en tout cas
sont un petit peu déçus
avant 15 millions et qui a été vendu
que 2 millions et demi d'euros par an à
peu près c'est ça
pour elle et un million et demi pour
elle je crois et un million que son
frère lui a donné qui a refusé de la
suppression et qui lui a été